like you know remember where was I going
what what question was I trying to pass
on I was interested in forces right now
I've got velocity I've got acceleration
how do I get from all this to forces
what extra needs to be included
yeah very good what I need is mass right
so I'm going to now a different game
words differently twice now if I include
mass in our expressions that'll get me
forces okay so for this guy over here
right this is by the way this is the
acceleration for X and this guy over
here is the acceleration for y okay just
as we just said the force so I've got a
horizontal voice it's just this with
mass included now all I have to do is
multiply by mass so that gives you this
and the same guy over here if I'm via
the forces acting vertically I'm going
to have minus M Omega squared so ideally
okay so I've got my values there so far
so good
okay now again I'm gonna keep on asking
questions what's interesting that I can
do with this now if you recall when we
talked earlier about objects they're
moving around around around they are not
experiencing a uniform straight-line
motion there is actually a force acting
on this and that's what causes it to
keep on curving round and round around
you remember that you put your diagram
in front of you
right so therefore if it keeps curving
back towards the center back towards the
center that means there must be a force
that is acting toward the center all the
time right and we said before they're
examples of like gravity or tension in
string or whatever kind of other forces
pull the you to the middle okay we call
that centripetal force because it's
towards the center that's what sent
remains okay so if you think about that
this will do okay if you think about
this situation what that means is if you
are drawing toward the center right
toward the center you have a resultant
force acting along this line okay now
keeping
keep in mind this is a tangent his
attention so this line here this axis
I've just introduced what is that it's
the normal because perpendicular to the
tangent right this is the normal so what
I'm interested in now is I know there's
a force acting in this direction because
it's um oriented along with all this is
often called the normal force so I want
to know what this normal force is okay
think of this just like we projectile
motion when you took like a horizontal
and a vertical component and you can jam
them together and make that ah this is
the velocity of the initial velocity
projection so I'm going to include those
so I want to do the same thing here but
it gets a bit confusing thinking about
things because this diagram at the
moment is operating up down left right
okay but I want to think about the
normal as my new up-down left-right okay
so I'm going to redraw this diagram I'd
like you to do the same and you can kind
of turn your page but I think it's
easier if you draw a whole new one so
that we can think of the normal this is
our real axis now that we're thinking
about okay
so effectively for this particular
diagram I'm basically going to redraw it
we rotated 45 degrees this way okay so
my fact is you're gonna look like this
alright now these are these horizontal
and vertical forces I already had them
on this diagram where are they going to
be on this new diagram is just oriented
a little bit different which way for
examples the horizontal force can be
facing could you describe it verbally
it's gonna be hanging off heading off to
the top right you see that it has to be
parallel to this fact because this of
course is the x axis so that's why the X
force is heading off that way okay so
here's FX and in the same way you're
gonna have this guy which is FY okay now
you can literally see right each of
these is contributing a little bit short
each of these is contributing part of
their force towards this direction maybe
see that so therefore I'll just put this
in a bit closer what I need to do is
resolve forces with regard to the normal
okay I'm trying to resolve the normal
force that's what I'm doing okay so in
order to do that I need a little bit of
extra information on my diagram firstly
I need to know where I am which is
defined by the angle so this is beat up
over here you can see you've got some
parallel lines happening right so
theater is also oh yeah do you agree
with that
that's just corresponding angle okay but
to work out how much present they just
figure out this guy over here the X bar
right there's a triangle in here like
that
like which is right angle and part of
this horizontal force is between this
amount to the normal force you see that
this is just like with projectile motion
okay so if beam is up here I'm gonna
redraw myself a new diagram this it's
just this triangle just by itself
you've got the normal head up in this
direction and then you've got the
horizontal force which when we're now
looking at an angle you got a right
angle theta and that's that magnitude
there okay so what I'm really interested
in is this quantity this quantity okay
so have a look using it's a right angle
triangle what tree to make sure ratio is
going to make this with this cos theta
is going to be this quantity adjacent on
hypotenuse right so if I call this let's
just call it like and for normal
related to X right so if I call me this
guy and X right
cos theta cos theta is going to be
adjacent on hypotenuse like and so you
can clearly see what is this it's just
going to be F X cos theta is that okay
you see how I've done that you see how I
just reasoned it geometry but I can do
exactly the same thing for the variable
force right it's just a little there's
just one more step of geometry that's
required okay having a look at that guy
right I'm going to again redraw this
diagram
a vertical force torn off in this
direction
and that's it's an attitude right I have
this line that joins me to the normal
okay
now coming back to this original diagram
how do I work out where theater is
because I want this all in terms of
theta yeah so where is theta now you can
kind of see because these two forces are
perpendicular to each other right this
guy here must be PI on to minus theta do
you agree that it's the complement which
makes if that's pilot to minus theta
this guy over here must be theta
do you see that so I'm going to put it
here right and here is the normal force
that comes from the vertical component
right so that's going to call that in Y
what ratio combines these two opposite
hypotenuse so you can clearly see here
if I want to know what's the amount
contributed to the normal force it's
going to be every Y so you can see that
nice pleasing symmetry to it
okay so where are we up to right we're
now trying to work out well the whole
amount of force going in that direction
now can anyone suggest to me
why have I defined that as positive even
though actually we already know the
force should be heading in this
direction
any suggestions
okay hold on a second
it is going towards the center that's
what makes it a circle right if it
weren't like constantly turning in this
way that's toward the center circuit
it's gonna be turning out that way which
is mean it's just gonna fly off
nothing's bring it back okay maybe a
friend the question be them clearly I'm
just trying to figure out whatever I
define this is positive like I can
defined this as positive or down as
positive why have I chosen this as the
direction of positive even though the
force that I know actually is acting in
that direction it must be toward the
center because I'm actually not just
trying to find the magnitude this is all
in terms of like these guys I haven't
said absolute value anyway so sign is
still preserved Jitsu no no no it
doesn't but you should know why you
should know why and there's a very
obvious reason
um what's this point here it's the
origin but it's zero zero so as you get
larger and larger values your numbers
are getting bigger right that way so it
doesn't make sense to call that positive
like human say oh yeah he's the x-axis
by the way that's negative like that's
confusing right don't don't make things
get bigger as they get close the origin
you should get bigger they go away from
the origin so that's why we've defined
that way that direction okay so now if I
combine these two together I'm gonna
call this F n the normal force what I
need to combine is these two guys here
right the normal force that comes from
the horizontal component and the normal
force that comes from the vehicle
component does that make sense so I'm
just going to add these just kind F of X
cos plus okay by the way that was my
answer to the question of why these guys
here are facing in those directions it's
because they want to match with the
normal force okay so in case you're
wondering okay what if F X good what's
what's that force it's right here is it
stay over here so therefore I would just
finish it when I multiply that
horizontal force by cos theta I'm going
to get minus M Omega squared cos squared
and then I take the vertical force and I
say it's minus M Omega squared right
this is this imbalance okay so you can
see I can clearly take a factor of
negative M R for being squared I get
left with cos squared plus sine squared
which of course is what
so this normal force right is just minus
M R Omega squared please put a big
colorful box around that it's a really
important statement okay and it's kind
of lovely because we weren't dealing
with all these angles and that kind of
thing but we said all along right this
meant a uniform circular motion like an
object moving under the force of gravity
okay well this is the force acting on
the normal number one tell me why it's
negative because if we define positive
as away from the origin we know the
normal force acting toward the origin
it's a centripetal force right so
therefore it's negative obviously the
master important the radius of your
motion is important then you've got
Omega and there's no theaters involved
why aren't there any theatres because
you're experiencing the same motion
sorry the same force always back to the
center I don't care where you are on the
circle it doesn't matter right it's not
relevant that's why if fact is that
reserve exit